with plate tectonics there is
a long way we've come since the theory
became sort of widely accepted about 50
years ago there's so much we still don't
know
and it's ideal as a researcher going
into a field where there's a lot of
unanswered questions
earth is over four billion years old
it's a long way back to look at
we're only seeing a very tiny portion of
earth's history
so extrapolating what we find out today
to the deep
time past it's a very big task
it's a bit like detective work you pick
on these clues and if you know how to
read the earth
and find these clues you can tell a lot
about
how earth has evolved today
the earth's lithosphere which is the
outer layer and it's formed by the crust
and the top part of the mantle
is broken into a number of tectonic
plates and those plates move
continuously and that's what what we
call plate tectonic theory tells us
about how that happens
originally when earth formed it would
have been too hot to have a crust it
would have been too hot to have plates
as it cooled down if the outside layer
would have solidified
but it wouldn't have been broken into
plates exactly when
it did break into pieces exactly how
that happened
we're not sure the suggestion is that
subduction
or the process of a plate sinking into
the mantle
was what initiated it because today we
think that subduction plays a big role
for plate tectonics
but exactly how or when
we just simply don't know
for reconstructing plate motions the
oceans themselves are our main source of
information
at mid-ocean ridges so places where two
plates are separating
new oceanic lithosphere is forming so
mid-ocean ridge essentially
is a very long chain of volcanoes and
the mantle is coming to the surface and
those
magma is coming to the sea floor in
contact with seawater
solidifying and when it does that the
magnetic minerals
in those rocks will align themselves
with the magnetic field of earth
back through time our magnetic field has
flipped at uneven intervals and the
ocean floor and the rocks forming on the
ocean floor are recording these flips in
polarity
we can look at the ocean floor and
record these signals
and essentially date the ocean floor and
know
how old it is in different places and
you can use those stripes to build
plate reconstructions so to essentially
bring
continents back together back through
time
there is a big connection between plate
tectonics and life
the main way in which plate tectonics
may have enabled
earth as a suitable environment
for life to appear and to evolve as
quickly as it has done
is that plate tectonics controls the
climate in many ways
one of the ways is that it controls the
carbon cycle so how
carbon is exchanged between the outside
and the inside of earth
the formation and the destruction of
oceans and how oceans connect
to other oceans and how water circulates
is the earth's thermostat
it controls the distribution of heat it
also controls the distribution of
nutrients
which are key for life so there are
suggestions that life appeared on earth
before plate tectonics
was underway but perhaps the difference
between earth and other planets is that
whilst plate tectonics
may not be a requirement for life to
appear in the first place
it's likely that it's a requirement for
life to be maintained and to diversify
and to grow as quickly as it did
[Music]
you